[Applause]  most teams work to against the pump W  had on free throws to will see that to  the house that kind of a at the  positioner of us a little bit more than  Jason Kidd on the standing beauty first  half flown yes I'm sure brick looks  benched it hazards but as you push us in  the building that's fly February fourth  Super Bowl Sunday in Brooklyn that'll be  an eleven o'clock central star crushing  just about everything 24 points he  crushes that 24 points in 16 minutes on  night reverse overlay here's Janice now  has 24 points tonight 26 in twenty  minutes  man teams and have time to come in and  score those first they beat the 200  points Janice  that's a tough shot Drucker back from  Dellavedova two defenders hanging around  the  Sunday introduction couple the handoffs  now Yanis eight on the shot clock  dribbles  [Applause]